madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
de l'actualité de ce lundi 30 juillet
les chefs 0 est mort dimanche soir à 79
ans dans sa maison de ronfleur ses
obsèques seront célébrées jeudi en plus
de 50 ans de carrière michel 0 avait
incarné des personnages les plus divers
avec l'eau sur ce plateau
régis farid au soir soit les prêteurs en
scène entre autres de parasites et
reviens tard qui est le dernier film
français tourné par les chasseurs et
puis deuxième grand disparition du
cinéma celle de ingmar bergman le
cinéaste suédois est mort aujourd'hui
dans sa maison sur l'île de phares en
mer baltique cinéaste de l'introspection
et des tourments sa mort plombe plonge
le monde du cinéma dans une profonde
affliction ouverture à l'assemblée
nationale du débat sur le service
minimum dans les transports un texte
critiquée à gauche et par les syndicats
mais un principe plébiscité par les
usagers
le chômage continue de baisser en france
avec man dans certains secteurs
d'éléments cruel de main d'oeuvre
nous le verrons ce journal le tour de
france 2007 une édition controversé même
si le succès public se dément pas les
organisateurs affirment que toute
l'organisation va être remise à plat
c'est donc à honfleur que michel
serrault s'est éteint dimanche soir
entouré de sa femme de sa fille et du
père de la morandais michel serrault
était un homme extravagant à la scène et
pudique à la ville un homme pieux qui
avouera que ses deux passions était de
faire rire et de s'occuper de dieu dès
demain les habitants de honfleur
pourront se recueillir devant sa
dépouille qui sera exposée dans sa
maison sur place dans le calvados
si les pros chaud et jacquard
c'est dans cette église sainte catherine
qu'auront lieu les funérailles de michel
serrault jeudi à honfleur
une église qui l'admirait car le toit
est fait avec la coque en bois d'un
bateau renversé on attend plusieurs
centaines de personnes mais pour l'heure
les curieux ne se bousculent pas devant
son manoir qui domine la mer
c'est pourtant bien là qu'il est mort
hier soir on a décidé de venir faire un
petit tour et lui faire un dernier petit
coucou puisque depuis je suis tout petit
je me dis s'il ya un acteur auquel
j'aimerais bien rendre hommage ci
disparaît un jour c'est bien lui
michel serrault et mais le calme qui se
dégage du port de honfleur
les conducteurs de calèches arbore
fièrement sa photo mais c'est à la
pharmacie qui l'a laissé le meilleur
souvenir
il avait eu un malaise en 2005 et pour
remercier le pharmacien de son aide
il a tenu le magasin pendant deux heures
pour la plus grande joie des clients
les gens le lui demander bas de caisse
bien ou et cheyrou lui répondais oui en
disant qu'ils qu'ils étaient ses thèmes
nouveaux pharmaciens de la place à blanc
le nouveau pharmacien de honfleur donc
il était bien dans ce rôle
alors ils étaient bien y jouer son rôle
dans le carnet de souvenirs du musée
alphonse allais on retrouve le visage de
michel serrault il aimait venir dans ce
petit musée pour y savourer l'humour
noir qui se dégage de trois pièces rares
exposé ici à savoir le crom de voltaire
enfants le vrai morceau de la fosse
croix du christ et une tasse avec lens à
gauche fabriqués spécialement pour
henning qui était gaucher et michel
serrault bien sûr s'était fait
photographier avec le crâne de voltaire
enfants michel serrault aurait voulu
être prêtre
et cette idée lui a tenu à coeur jusqu'à
la fin de sa vie il l'a confié
d'ailleurs ou prêtre qui lui a donné
l'extrême onction
il revenait toujours sur son histoire de
vocation quand il avait 14 ans qui
voulait être prêtre et qu'elle aime il a
eu la chance de tomber sur un curé pas
trop quand le père van damme qui aime
beaucoup et d'en parler encore et qui
l'a orienté vers ce seul pourquoi il
était fait michel serrault n'avait
apparemment laissé aucune consigne pour
ses funérailles et c'est à l'initiative
de ses amis que la population de
l'ampleur devrait défiler demain matin
devant son domicile pour lui rendre
hommage
l'âme de charlie chaplin dans un corps
d'apothicaire c'est ainsi qu'il se
dépeignait lui même
il fait l'inoubliable zaza napoli de la
cage aux folles avec son ami et compère
jean poiret mais on verra aussi dans des
rôles plus noir comme dans garde à vue
ou dans nelly et monsieur arnaud
portrait de ce comédien exceptionnel
signé pascal deschamps est un con il
était comme ça michel serrault et il
savait de quoi il parlait lui qui érigea
l'amusement en art suprême et pas
seulement dans ces rôles sur celle au
cinéma ou à la télévision non dans la
vie quotidienne aussi fait rire les
autres fut pour lui tout autant une
nécessité qu'une forme de politesse une
forme de provocation aussi une manière
bien à lui de prendre le contre pied
pour ne pas trop se prendre au sérieux
j'étais au séminaire pendant deux ans et
j'ai donc je reste est très ami avec le
prêtre comme je connaissais à cette
époque là et puis bon bout de deux ans
je suis sorti le supérieur mal et vous
êtes très gentil tout va bien mais je
crois quand même que votre place sur les
planches parce que je m'amusais beaucoup
où ces mêmes mots séminaire il y avait
des occasions de rire les planches
l'accueil dès 1946 il a 18 ans mais
c'est sa rencontre avec jean poiret en
1952 qui fait décoller sa carrière
le duo fait les beaux soirs des cabarets
parisiens et de la rtf la
radiotélédiffusion française une essence
les deux stars de l'époque vont s'offrir
l'un des plus grands succès théâtraux de
tous les temps la cage aux folles
l'un l'a écrit et l'interprète mais
l'autre va littéralement exploser dans
le rôle du travesti albin mougeotte 10
zaza napoli aux avis que la tablette ne
l'avait pas
un million de spectateurs en septembre
et bientôt un film qui en rassembleront
plus de 8
qu'est ce que tu fais pendant que je
suis en chaîne ou est-ce que tu traînes
à ce moment là michel serre on a déjà 70
films derrière lui mais pour le monde du
cinéma comme pour le grand public et
devient alors ce monstre sacré est
capable de tout jouer
il y a bien eu le viager de son copain
tchernia il y admire son autre complice
jean pierre mocky qui le premier lui a
offert déroule dix ans décalé aussi
seigneur je te demande encore ce soir de
nous en délivre les mavs rg moi mais
c'est bien à la fin des années 70 que
michel serrault se verra offrir les
rôles tragiques dans lesquelles il
excellera comme garde à vue écrit pour
lui par michel audiard et qui lui vaudra
son second césar il y joue un notaire
accusé du meurtre d'une enfant tout à
peut pas sauvage pour un sauvetage et où
les questions les réponses elles sont
tellement ignoble vos questions que vous
en avez honte c'est pas vrai peut-être
jouer quelqu'un qui est un qui est un
exemple de moralité et qu'un être humain
un magnifique enfin disent pas bon bon
bien sûr c'est très bien mais jouer le
contraire pour moment pour des pour
jouer incarner la connerie ou la
méchanceté ou là enfin vraiment tout ce
qu'on peut tout ce qu'il ya de s est
aussi c'est aussi magnifique je trouve
regardez ce cas quelqu'un capable de
et dans le genre avec le docteur potiez
où il est servi ce médecin malade mental
qui assassina des dizaines de gens
pendant la guerre dont il brûlait les
dépouilles dans sa cave
un monstre et lorsque je m'entraîne
randonnée l'histoire d'un père dont la
fille est morte car tout le monde pense
à celle qu'il a perdue caroline mais
dans un accident de la route
je crois en dieu si vous voulez suivre
elle est bien de temps en temps je
m'écroule et jeudi je vous comprends pas
dieu je te comprends pas il tourne pour
la première fois avec lucho tu es pour
lui il sera monsieur arnaud regardez
vous êtes là projet devant être pas jean
comme un ectoplasme vous allez arrêter
nous prenez pour qui
le cédant est attribué à monsieur michel
serrault chaque séance pour ce rôle tout
en pudeur il reçoit donc son troisième
césar et la standing-ovation de toute
une profession
c'est je crois que c'est plus facile
pour moi de faire le pitre que de
recevoir le césar je voulais vous dire
avec toute mon amitié
merci michel serre on ne dira jamais non
à ce monde du cinéma qui ne cesse de le
solliciter faire sa part quelques
exceptions ont lieu surtout désormais
des rôles de grand-père plus ou moins
bourgault temps en temps je me dis
est-ce que stromae et mon médecin que
j'aime beaucoup qui est très très bon
médecin et anna mais il m'a dit de
michel tourne tourne lui qui admirait
tant les clowns en fuite un avec tout le
tragique qui se cachent derrière leur
nez rouge mais aussi ce goût de
l'enfance jamais bien loin
je pense que j'ai pas perdu trop de mon
enfance j'ai pas perdu trop de mes
espérances
je pense que je suis prêt à repartir à
zéro et surtout j'ai surtout pas je
crois une autre vie
et en effet jusqu'au bout ils sincères
aura continué de tourner de jean pierre
mocky à pierre tchernia tous ceux qui
l'ont côtoyé où l'on fait travailler sa
lune exceptionnel virtuosité roma mais
qui aura pas on ne rend pas sourd à la
colère à la godille à la gandhi allaient
faire vieillir amuser les autres bien au
delà de ses espérances michel serrault
aura marqué les français populaire
comiques ou dramatiques capable de tout
jouer de toucher tous les publics sur
tout ce que je retiens de lui c'est que
c'était un homme authentique mais je
pense que des acteurs authentique à la
présidence il était capable de faire des
rôles hypersensible et en même temps des
rôles avec une finesse et légèreté que
nous faisons nous avons en tartine art
de basket il était pas mal pendant
le veer son fonds de commerce
son lien privilégié avec le public
michel serrault excellait dans l'art du
burlesque et pas seulement au cinéma le
paris dakar et le journal des courses la
nette de la météo de nos payes oui oui
elle va être content d'avoir deux bouts
dans ce journal
un comique qui ne laissait jamais rien
au hasard
le vieux monsieur martin à du viager un
jour quelques semaines avant de
commencer il m'a dit tu sais je vais
penser à ma grand mère ah bon et c'était
absolument pas sa grand-mère qui
limitait mais se souvenait de la façon
d'être de sa grand mère et donc il
essayait de donner un peu de cette
vérité aux personnages
j'sais pas dans ta life
en 50 ans de scène du théâtre à l'écran
michel serrault est devenu une référence
pour ses compagnons de route un monstre
sacré d'hommes qui est d'acteurs qui
pouvait très bien se projeter d'un seul
coup dans dans un vieux pépé qui pêche à
la grenouille alors que c'était c'est
magnifique de tourner comme ça si je lui
rends hommage aujourd'hui c'est pour en
souvenir de tous les acteurs comme
michel simon et ses acquis aider les
réalisateurs qui ne se contente pas
seulement de prendre de l'argent mais
qui venaient les aider les aider à faire
des oeuvres qui reste dans le cinéma qui
resteront et lui restera avec ses 135
films
même les plus mauvais y restera parce
que il avait une telle personnalité que
on l'oublira jamais on perd un immense
acteur il est remplaçable comme raimu
houga ben voilà c'est julia ce sont des
moules cassé on en trouve qu'on va
retrouver tout de suite
michel serrault s'imaginait volontiers
en clown clown drôle parfois de liste
dont on sait aujourd'hui s'il faut en
rire ou en pleurer
et avec nous je le disais régis wargnier
vous avez tourné avec michel serrault
pars vite et reviens tard avant
d'évoquer l'acteur est ce qu'on peut
parler de l'homme parce qu'il se savait
malade
c'est un homme qui était extravagant sur
scène on l'a vu et en même temps
extrêmement pudique à la ville si je
finis difficile 1 2 de parler après tout
ces images michel était un homme
extrêmement extrêmement ouverts en même
temps extrêmement secret et j'aurais
l'impression peut-être de trahir de
trahir son sa volonté de rêve de rester
dans l'ombre mais c'est vrai je crois
que le plus important à part son métier
dans sa vie c'était vraiment sa famille
il était vraiment très proche de sa
femme et de sa fille surtout apprendre à
la tragédie de la perte de l'une de ses
filles dans un accident est bien sûr et
puis il s'était peu à peu éloigné du
monde michel était quelqu'un qu'on ne
voyait jamais dans l'est dans les
soirées parisiennes il vivait à neuilly
d'avant du maïs est installé il
s'installe à honfleur et me me parlait
souvent cette maison en disant qu'il
avait une salle qui est un pin salle de
méditation de recueillement il parlait
aussi beaucoup très très clairement de
sa foi de dieu parce que c'est nous on a
beaucoup tourné de nuit donc c'est
propice aux confidences
il me il était étonné que des gens
puissent vivre sans lieu où ça en
religion ça ne l'a pas empêché pourtant
de tourner dans des films totalement
iconoclaste à l'égard de l'église jeu
sur l'ibis rouge mais a dû l'aider mais
parce que ses notes justement c'est vrai
mais je pense que c'est je dis pas qui
séparait les choses mais il faut ni puis
faisait la part des choses entre entre
une pitrerie une clownerie un texte et
puis et puis ses profondes convictions
vous savez des idées il avait comme
acteur quelque chose de fascinant c'est
que jorge ait jamais vu quelqu'un faire
un grand écart paraît y entraient c'est
vrai qu'entre aux hasards napoli et puis
les gardes à vue par exemple
mais les vieux messieurs bonjour
sensible et je suis absent qu'au-delà de
au delà de son sens du comique si vous
regardez bien la cage aux folles il
finit par nous émouvoir avec ce
personnage totalement caricatural et
finit par en faire un être humain est
dépassée la caricature et en même temps
que vous voyez garde à vue
il va chercher en lui quelque chose
d'extrêmement profond il va chercher
très loin qu'il faut sur la noirceur de
l'homme
je pense que peu de peu d'acteurs en ce
sens ce tempérament excès d'artistes et
il lisait au qu'il ne s'intéressait pas
au réel et que son seul but c'était au
fond de partage et de rires c'est aussi
ça qui nourrit c'est peut-être cette
virtuosité d'acteurs formidables
oui mais je pense qu'il avait 20 cents
par will le réel je dirais le quotidien
je croit l'intéressé pas trop de c'est
quelqu'un qui était temps en qui était
un grand lit un grand lecteur un grand
diseur qui était aussi un homme d'un
homme de méditation ce qu'effectivement
n'est pas évident quand on quand on le
voit travailler mais dans son travail il
avait
il avait ce plaisir absolu du jeu je
pense que c'est juste passer un don de
naissance ou c'est quelque chose qu'on
attrape comme une bonne maladie mais il
avait quand il avait sur le plateau il y
avait les lumières les partenaires et
envoyé cet homme je veux dire alors que
j étais fatigué quand ils travaillent
avec nous vous voyez cet homme reprendre
une vie et une forme une énergie
extraordinaire parce qu' il allait
accomplir son travail
alors y est il ya une palette en tout
cas de personnages qui n'a pas joué même
si il a joué un peu là la passion mais
en tout cas il n'a jamais été dans des
rôles des du séducteur plus jeune
premier non mais je pense que je connais
sens assez bien michel je pense que
c'est les connaissant sa pudeur je pense
même qu'il aurait été incapable je pense
pas qu'on aurait pu le mettre au lit
avec une actrice si ce serait tellement
marre et je pense qu'on aurait les
cheveux c'est peut-être une défense je
crois ça fait partie de son
extraordinaire pudeur alors qu'il avait
une immense impudeur a raconté des
personnages troubles et troublant
dangereux noir désespérer revers est
justement ce matin en suède une vision
tout à l'heure en titre dans l'équipe
c'est un immense cinéaste peut être un
des derniers géants du cinéma mondial
ingmar bergman qui s'est éteint à l'âge
de 89 ans sur l'île de france où il
avait tourné plusieurs de ses films son
oeuvre a marqué des générations de
cinéphiles de cinéastes dont woody allen
qui lui vouent un véritable culte
emmanuel lambert faire des films un
instinct besoin pour bergman en 2003
après 20 ans d'absence au cinéma
le suédois revenait à la réalisation lui
qui avait annoncé la fin de sa carrière
mais avec le film sarabande il
retrouvait s'amuser ex-femme l'actrice
liv ullman
le problème c'est que je tombe toujours
amoureux de mon actrice principale
ça n'a pas toujours servi à grand chose
donc on essaie plutôt merhige
fils d'un pasteur luthérien ingmar
bergman est né près de stockholm en 1918
passionné de théâtre il décide
finalement de passer derrière la caméra
1955 son premier succès international
sourires d'une nuit d'été et force des
gros plans soin apporté à la lumière le
suédois était un réalisateur de génie
mais il n'a jamais fait l'unanimité
pour certains le style bergman et roland
et ennuyeux pour d'autres chaque plan
est une leçon de cinéma je le prépare
toujours très soigneusement et longtemps
avant le tournage
j'essaie de tout noter vous pourriez
croire que c'est confus mais ça ne l'est
pas du tout nous avons été très proches
l'autre samedi à travers 50 longs
métrages bergman a tenté de sonder l'âme
humaine ses thèmes de prédilection
l'amour la sexualité
l'angoissé de la mort en 74 son film
scènes de la vie conjugale décrit les
difficultés du couple à une citerne en
face à l'amour ces gens tiennent à je
suis trop fatigué en 1982
hollywood lui décerne quatre oscars pour
fanny et alexandre puis en 1997 à cannes
une palme des palmes couronne l'ensemble
de son oeuvre c'est démodé mais moi je
crois au contraire qu'il est le
commencement du cinéma mode
et quand vous de vous retourner à ses
purées ou alors le cinéma perdra son âme
dès ce matin en suède les drapeaux ont
été mis en berne les chaînes de télé ont
chamboulé leur programmation
un hommage national pour l'un des
derniers géants du septième art on
évoque avec vous un instant michel
serrault là on a une personnalité
opposée si je puis dire des tourments de
l'âme
l'absence de dieu sur terre toutes ces
questions cela ou bien sûr si neymar
succès au cinéma rébarbatif voudrait
kiki qui voit cris et chuchotements
sonate d'automne ou fait lexandre qui
sont nées les filles de sa deuxième
période
je pense que c'est de bergman était en
tout cas pour les gens de ma génération
c'était un éveil à la vie un événement
cinéma c'est un cinéaste immense qui
influence énormément
je regrette beaucoup qu'aujourd'hui j'ai
l'impression que la jeunesse
mais même les jeunes signifie sont assez
imperméable haberman parce que aller
voir un film de bergman c'était un acte
volontaire on va au cinéma où là il y
avait des images au rendu des images un
avis elles sont partout elles sont dans
la rue elle sans la télévision les clips
les pubs elles vont très vite
je crois que les gens donc plus là non
plus le temps la patience d'accepter
qu'une image et en vous tous les fascine
et sa lente et 8 soit landes et surtout
qu'elle soit envoûtant genre hautement
ça demande du temps et donc se disent
les villes mana à cannes ce qu'elle
disait est tout à fait juste
oui oui de du cinéma comme le septième
art je pense que il en est un des plus
grands sinon de plus grand est
je regrette que qu'on n'apprenne pas aux
gens à découvrir et à l'est mais
souhaitons en tout cas quand en effet
les jeunes retournent voir au cinéma les
films de ingmar bergman
merci régis wargnier j'ajoute que france
2 diffusera justement jeudi sonate
d'automne
s'il me tourner en 1978 précisément avec
liv ullmann le tribunal d'avignon a
condamné à des peines de prison avec
sursis 3 infirmière et une aide
soignante qui avait harcelé leurs chefs
de service et contester leur autorité
les peines de prison sont pour certaines
assorties d'une interdiction
professionnelle
le rappel des faits le compte rendu
d'audience avec anne icart aussi et
christophe laroque deux ans de prison
avec sursis 18 mois d'interdiction
d'exercer son métier d'infirmière à la
sortie de l'audience vanessa constant
craque elle est reconnue coupable entre
autres de harcèlement et
d'administration de substance nuisible
des faits qu'elle continue de nier se
pose en elle-même en victime
c'est j'ai été harcelée par mes
supérieurs pas moins des mois j'ai
signalé ce genre de problème à la
direction multiples fois voilà bah
frotte les trois autres accusés ont été
condamnés à des peines de deux à quinze
mois de prison avec sursis assorties
pour deux d'entre elles d'interdiction
d'exercer la justice est passée mais le
flou demeure autour des faits car au
cours des débats il ya un mois aucune
preuve ni aucun témoignage précis
n'était venue appuyer l'accusation
la direction de l'hôpital est alerté en
2006 à propos de problèmes dans le
service de chirurgie thoracique où
l'ambiance est détestable
les deux infirmières chef se disent
victimes de harcèlement moral
coup de téléphone malveillants en
voiture endommagée et même injection de
calmants et autres médicaments dans
leurs aliments ou leur boisson
je pensais être victimes de
de l'axé active dans mes
dans mes boissons et moi j'avais pu
surprendre sur que non il y en avait qui
surveiller c'était un gang est
aujourd'hui les deux infirmières se font
refuser de s'exprimer
deux des infirmières condamnés ont
annoncé leur intention de faire appel
hier soir l'assemblée nationale du débat
sur le service minimum dans les
transports
le texte a déjà été adopté par le sénat
il devrait passer sans grande difficulté
à l'assemblée
même si la gauche accuse le gouvernement
de provocation alexandre kara et à la
location débat à grande vitesse sur le
service minimum il était l'une des
priorités du candidat sarkozy
il devrait être le dernier acte de cette
session extraordinaire pour le
gouvernement le service minimum c'est
aussi le service public le service
minimum ce n'est pas une question de
droite ou une question de gauche
le service minimum c'est tout simplement
une question de service public pour
désamorcer la polémique la stratégie de
la majorité est simple jouer la carte
des usages il peut comprendre que en
2007 il ya un certain nombre de deux
salariés qui considère que tout en
respectant le droit de grève il faut
pouvoir aller bosser et que est pénalisé
par la grève c'est c'est quand même très
compliqué notamment dans les transports
principale disposition du texte
l'obligation pour les entreprises
d'élaborer un plan de transport minimum
avant le 1er janvier 2008 mais pour les
syndicats
jusqu'à présent le dialogue n'a pas eu
les perturbations et nous avons eu à
faire un simulacre de concertation
on nous a écouté poliment la cgt a pris
toute sa part dans ce processus en
faisant des contre-propositions en
déposant des amendements mais le
gouvernement n'a pas tenu compte
autre mesure contestée par la gauche le
vote à bulletin secret après huit jours
de conflit pour décider de la poursuite
d'une grève mais surtout l'article qui
oblige le salarié à se déclarer
grévistes ou non
48 heures à l'avancé c'est un article
qui est là pour faire peur
pour dissuader le salarié qui voudraient
faire grève de faire grève c'est donc un
article qui va remettre en cause
subrepticement le droit de grève contre
cet article les députés ps ont
l'intention de saisir le conseil
constitutionnel
quant aux syndicats de cheminots ils
appellent dès demain à des
rassemblements dans toute la france côté
usagers on est évidemment favorable au
service minimum même si on constate que
les perturbations les plus importantes
sont le faits d'incidents techniques à
répétition
plus que deux mouvements de grève
reportage julien dupéré est thomas
donzel
le service minimum les usagers sont
plutôt pour mais de l'allier directement
toutes les perturbations aux grèves
il y à un quels qu'ils ne franchissent
pas travailler à paris c'est minimum
deux fois par semaine
2 milliards $ c'est pas trois jours de
gran manic qui pose de gros problèmes
en fait depuis 2003 et les grèves contre
la réforme des retraites le nombre moyen
de jours de grève par agent sncf est
quasiment toujours en baisse une baisse
favoriser pour certains usagers par le
dispositif d'alarmé sociale déjà
vachement améliorée par rapport aux
autres années mais surtout maintenant en
plus on est prévenu il ya un an
tif du mmm ne fait que légiférer sur
quelque chose qui est déjà en place dans
les entreprises pour les voyageurs la
plupart des perturbations sont causées
par un manque de moyens
y a plein des rousses et des trains
l'espèce de bétail et à grise là qui
sont insupportables et qu'on laisse ça à
des gens depuis je peux être candidat
peut-être un meilleur des situations
surtout vrai sur le réseau régional de
la sncf pour son amélioration
100 millions d'euros seront déboursés
l'année prochaine et 1000 personnes
embauchées et dans le métro parisien au
lendemain de l'incident qui a perturbé
le trafic sur la ligne 13 on connaît un
peu mieux l'origine de l'incendié au
cours duquel une dizaine de personnes
ont été légèrement intoxiquées
retour sur l'une des lignes les plus
fréquentées de paris est aussi l'une des
plus vétustes même si les incidents
importants dans le métro sont rarissimes
si vers le petit et pascal cas c'est
cette pièce de la ram qui a pris feu
hier matin sur la ligne 13 selon la ratp
une canette de soda a dû se coincer
entre l'alimentation électrique en bas
de l'écran et la suspension la partie
noire éventré le court circuit a
provoqué un début d'incendié
nous avions à cette hauteur là
l'équivalent d'un termini chalumeau qui
a fait qu'effectivement cette partie en
caoutchouc s'est mise à chauffer le
conducteur a rapidement éteint le feu la
fumée
intoxiqué légèrement une dizaine de
personnes dont une femme enceinte
ce n'est pas la vétusté des trains qui
est en cause la rame mise en service au
début des années 80 venez de passer un
contrôle de sécurité
il y a dix jours ce sont des rames qui
sont parfaitement entretenu avec un
programme qui est régulier nous avons
des visites de sécurité tous les 6500 km
le problème vient plutôt de l'âge des
tunnels la plupart datent du début du
siècle la ligne 13 est une des plus
chargée du réseau parisien
un demi million de personnes
l'empruntent chaque jour aujourd'hui
bien peu s'inquiète de l'accident de la
veille
ça peut pas rêver c'est pas très
fréquent donc j'ai pas l'impression
d'être en danger quand je prends le
métro j'étais choqué parce que c'est
celle que je prends tous les jours
depuis depuis cinq six ans
quand même
chaque année la ratp connaît 300000
incident mais 80% d'entre eux sont
réglés en moins de cinq minutes
le dernier mort dans un accident la date
de 1981 nouvelles améliorations pour les
chiffres du chômage au mois de juin et
une baisse de 1 2% depuis le mois de mai
non de chômage est passé sous la barre
des 2 millions et désormais il s'établit
à 8% de la population active en un an le
nombre de demandeurs d'emploi a diminué
de 10 % dans certains bassins d'emploi
on manque aujourd'hui des candidats
certains postes notamment dans
l'industrie des transports et en face il
ya des chômeurs qui n'ont pas forcément
les qualifications demandées
reportage au havre séverine lebrun et
marie cazaux une usine pétrochimique
dans la banlieue du havre depuis plus de
40 ans on y fabrique des additifs pour
lubrifiants les typologies environnement
logiquement 10 personnes et est mort
hier trois personnes
combien de temps depuis à peu près des
cdi à pourvoir immédiatement et aucun
amateur pour les saisir
ça fait des mois que ça dure difficile à
gérer pour l'équipe en place
concrètement depuis début de l'année
c'est plusieurs samedis travaillés et
quelques heures fait aussi le soir après
après les heures normales de travail
voici la salle de contrôle ces
opérateurs sont chargés de piloter les
unités de production
ici aussi cinq postes sont vacants faute
de candidats qualifiés tous mes
confrères sont confrontés au même
problème
et aujourd'hui nous sommes parfois tenus
de réduire l'activité de certaines
chaînes de production car nous n'avons
pas le personnel en nombre pour produire
ces unités dans le bassin du havre une
entreprise sur deux aurait du mal à
recruter industrie transports bâtiments
manque de bras alors que douze mille
chômeurs se pressent dans les ape
mais les secteurs qui recrutent ne sont
pas forcément ceux qui les attire j'ai
pensé va demander de changer de
directement de de métier mais c'est vrai
que de la vente je suis plus dans la
vente que qu'autre chose savaient pas
envie de changer en fait non pas
vraiment à long terme je cherche comme
le métier qui m'intéresse et et dans
lequel j'ai fait mes études
l'équipe qu'est ce que c'est alors si
les objectifs dans ce centre de
formation on a donc décidé de faire du
sur mesure
si une entreprise humaine a recruté une
formation et mise en place rien que pour
elle et ça marche
tout ça ça réussit plutôt bien quand
même parce que si on prend nos taux de
deux contrats de travail à la sortie de
la formation
on arrive à des taux de 90 95 % des cdi
assuré à condition que les formations
soient bien ciblées
voilà toute la difficulté demain le
premier ministre françois fillon tiendra
un séminaire à matignon pour recadrer le
budget 2008 avec l'ensemble du
gouvernement
d'ores et déjà on sait qu'il faudra
trouver 10 à 11 milliards d'euros pour
financer les réformes fiscales annoncées
par le président de la république autre
question sensible le nombre de
fonctionnaires ils seront 80 2000 à
partir à la retraite en 2008 le tour de
france 2007 a été un incontestable
succès populaire que ce soit le long des
routes ou à la télévision
même s'il a été entaché par les affaires
de dopage on appris par ailleurs que le
coureur alexandre vinokourov exclu pour
dopage pendant le tour avait été
licencié aujourd'hui par son équipe
astana milan de ce tour de france en
chiffre avait 40 ans
le plus impitoyable des feuilletons de
l'été de la souffrance de la tricherie à
maillot jaune limogé des acteurs au bord
de la crise de nerfs c'est le tour de
france demi ce sont 41 coureurs au
générique de fin sur les champs elysées
soit 48 abandon les affaires ont pesé
lourd dans la balance sur les 540
contrôles effectués sur le tour à ce
jour de cas positifs
le kazakh vinokourov mais aussi
l'italien moreno rasmussen mais a dû
quitter le tour il avait menti sur ses
lieux d'entraînement et échapper à des
contrôles inopinés pour la première fois
depuis sa fuite il a parlé aujourd'hui
il prétend ne pas comprendre pourquoi
son équipe n'a exclu vous êtes vous déjà
dopé non absolument pas il faut quand
même préciser que depuis le 30 juin
jusqu'à ce que je sois exclu j'ai subi
17 contrôle antidopage tous négatifs a
certes le tour se porte mal mais cette
année au moins il a un vainqueur alberto
contador
accueilli en héros cet après midi à
l'aéroport de madrid
un beau gosse espagnol de 24 ans au
sourire d'ange mais au coup de [ __ ]
démoniaque sur le plateau de beille à 25
km heure de moyenne
il a fait mieux qu'un certain lance
armstrong 2004 des athlètes qui sont
convaincus de dopage de manière
incroyable et 2007 des athlètes qui sont
même si les conditions sont pas tout à
fait les mêmes
largement supérieurs à ce qu'ils étaient
nos pme mais contador a le bénéfice du
doute et certains chiffres avec lui
39,23 km heure de moyenne
l'espagnol est aller moins vite qu'à mme
strongle lors de son tour record en 2005
41,65 km/heure et quelle que soit la
vitesse des coureurs au bord des routes
la même ferveur 15 millions de
spectateurs de tout voile et côté télé
des audiences en hausse avec 3 millions
600 mille téléspectateurs en moyenne sur
chaque étape un tour malmené mais un
tour a dû les rendez-vous en 2008 pour
la suite du feuilleton de l'été préféré
des français
football rencontre entre deux clubs
autre famille tic nantes et reims
aujourd'hui en ligue 2 difficile pour
les nantais fort de huit titres de
champion de france de se retrouver en
deuxième division après 44 ans passés
parmi l'élite
j'y viens pas sec david fosse à nantes
fait la grimace après 44 ans passés dans
l'élite ce club historique du football
français se retrouvent dans l'anonymat
de la ligue 2 impensable il ya encore
quelques années pour la maison jaune qui
doit désormais faire face à une nouvelle
réalité un incident delà de la descente
ne pouvez jamais arrivé au fc nantes
elle s'est produite donc il faut la
gérer pour revenir aux vraies valeurs et
aux vraies fondations que le fc nantes
c'est à dire la formation didier
deschamps ou marcel desailly de grands
noms ont été formés à l'école nantaise
c'était l'époque où les canaris gagné
huit titres de champion trois coupes de
france et deux trophées des champions la
saison dernière a été un long calvaire
au bout duquel les supporters à bout de
nerfs ont envahi le terrain lors de la
dernière journée des heures de gloire à
la descente les plus anciens en tout
connu et ne sont pas forcément optimiste
j'espère que
ça va être de meilleures années qui vont
nous attendre devant si on arrive à
remonter de suite ce serait super mais
il ya beaucoup de boulot
oliech est parti bon partage on n'en
parle pas barthez et les autres stars
sont partis la pression est forte sur
les joueurs moins connus qui les ont
remplacés
j'espère qu'on va remonter assez
rapidement le sénat doit être l'équipe a
attendu dans tous les stades de france
donc j'espère qu'on va avoir des joueurs
qui vont mouiller le maillot
avec un budget de 20 millions d'euros
nantes sera de loin l'écurie la plus
fortunée de la ligue 2 est le
grandissime favori pour la remontée dans
la baie de cannes des îles de lerins se
font face l'une d'entre elles abritent
une abbaye cistercienne vieille de mille
six cents ans moines y accueille pour
quelques nuits ceux qui veulent se
reposer loin du tumulte de la côte
d'azur et la clientèle ne manque pas
reportage renaud bernard et alain dumas
voici la plage de l'hôtel le plus
insolite de la côte d'azur l'abbaye deux
îles de lérins et ses moines cisterciens
qui vous accueille à la réception je
lâche 1 37 euros la nuit en pension
complète
bush angles sont ici
le confort est spartiate mais le cadre
est unique
l'hôtellerie vont 4000 nuitées par
saison
la majorité des résidents sont des
jeunes on aime bien s'ils en ont envie
calme
voilà de quoi sarko des impôts les deux
façades de la côte d'azur
on peut bien le tumulte ma la cause
depuis et l'affairé montée de glénac
trois jours mais reste de l'année au
programme baignade et méditation une
seule règle a observé le silence pour
respecter la vie des moines qui pris
huit fois par jour
l'abbaye de lérins accueille la jeunesse
mais ici on n'est pas à saint tropez
n'était pour que mais qui reste une île
comme sa fille film cry lebel fait qu'il
a une histoire de ce siècle et c'est
qu'il ya toujours des moines prix
c'est une île qu'ils épargnent le centre
une île à seulement 30 minutes de bateau
de cannes et de l'agitation de la côte
d'azur
une île avec ses touristes pourtant où
seuls les chants grégoriens viennent
concurrencer celui des cigales
puis arnaud quitter aussi pour le
plaisir un extrait de la cage aux folles
regarder faire on n'est pas brutal russe
par l'american de l'homme voilà avec
tous les doigts dessus bras là la
cuillère dans la constitution n'ont pas
le droit la cuillère non pas comme ça la
cuillère tonus solidement
par une cuillère à pot non plus
je vivrai je viens t'en supplie de
couleur ni je parle s'il te plaît parce
que j'ai je suis dit voilà je me
rappelle que ce soir france 2 bouleverse
ses programmes pour une soirée spéciale
consacrée à michel serrault ainsi se
termine cette édition à suivre la météo
laurent romejko et puis donc de deux
moments forts pour michel serrault avec
le film le bonheur est dans le pré 2
etienne chatiliez suivi de la
rediffusion d'un vivement dimanche
consacré justement à l'acteur de maths
réserve ou retrouver david bauer il je
vous retrouve demain 20h très bonne
soirée sur france 3
une dispute